bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regardez mission spéciale ce soir
consacré à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur la réforme des
retraites il était 18h quand le verdict
des 9 sages est tombé la réforme est
pour l'essentiel validé certains
articles sont censurés nous verrons
lesquels on va faire bien sûr le tour
des réactions politiques nous serons
place de l'Hôtel de Ville à Paris avec
Stéphanie Despierre et Marco pommier
c'est là que les opposants à la réforme
se sont rassemblés à l'appel des
syndicats validations partielles donc du
texte et rejet du Rip le référendum
d'initiative partagée on va avoir
pourquoi dans le détail que peut-il se
passer maintenant on va tout vous
expliquer ça vous regarde spécial club
de fin ou pas sur les retraites c'est
parti
[Musique]
rarement sous la Cinquième République
une décision du Conseil constitutionnel
n'aura été aussi attendu la mesure phare
de la réforme le report de l'âge légal à
64 ans a donc été validé mais pas
l'index senior et 6 autres cavaliers
législatif on va y revenir la demande
d'un référendum d'initiative partagée a
aussi été rejeté et le bras de fer
continue dès ce soir dans la rue un peu
partout en France bonsoir Roland Carole
et merci d'être notre grand témoin ce
soir politologue directeur de recherche
au CNRS l'un des plus fin connaisseurs
de la 5ème république auquel à laquelle
vous consacrez votre dernier ouvrage mon
voyage au cœur de la Cinquième
République avec Arnaud Mercier chez
Kalman Lévy bonsoir Paul Cassia vous
êtes professeur de droit public à
l'Université Paris implanté on Sorbonne
vous avez signé une tribune détaillée
sur le rip dans le monde le référendum
d'initiative partagée avec une analyse
différente de celle des juges
constitutionnels ce soir on revient
droit et puis trois politiques en PLA
bonsoir vous êtes député renaissance de
nouvelles Calédonie Sandrine Rousseau
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes député
Europe Écologie Les Verts de Paris et
bonsoir Bertrand pencher bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député de la Meuse
et président du groupe liotte ce fameux
groupe à l'Assemblée liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire à l'origine de
la motion de censure du gouvernement
rejeté on s'en souvient de 9 voix
seulement c'était le 20 mars dernier
avant de vous donner la parole madame et
messieurs on va se plonger dans le
détail sur cette décision du Conseil
d'abord sur la réforme des retraites en
elle-même elles a mon dingava revient
tout juste de la rue de Montpensier on
l'accueille tout de suite
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
alors ça y est cette décision très
attendue est tombée et vous y étiez
exactement c'était un petit peu avant
18h regardez où on était on était une
centaine de journalistes dans une salle
du Conseil constitutionnel une
invitation inédite pour un briefing sur
la décision des sages enfin plutôt un
débriefing puisque quelques minutes
avant 18h l'Agence France Presse avait
donné les informations et regardez pour
y accéder à ce Conseil constitutionnel
on a dû montrer patte blanche trois
contrôles de cartes de presse puisqu'il
ressemble à ça en ce moment des murs
anti des murs de barricades devant le
Conseil constitutionnel ça c'est
l'anecdotique pour le fond Myriam vous
l'avez dit le Conseil constitutionnel a
validé et bien l'essentiel de la réforme
puisque regardez c'est bon pour les la
fin des régimes spéciaux ça l'est aussi
pour le cœur de la réforme le report de
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans alors les
oppositions contestaient la méthode
notamment ce qu'on appelle le véhicule
législatif le fait d'être passé par un
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
regardez ce qu'on tranchait les sages le
choix qui a été fait à l'origine par le
gouvernement de les faire figurer au
sein d'une loi de financement
rectificative ne méconnait en lui-même
aucune exigence constitutionnelle il y
avait d'autres griefs prononcés par les
oppositions l'utilisation d'outils
certes constitutionnelle mais leur
accumulation avait fait débat on s'en
souvient ici à l'Assemblée nationale le
47 ans pour limiter la longueur des
débats le 49-3 pas de vote à l'issue des
débats au Sénat il y a eu l'article 38
le 44 3 j'arrête ici le Conseil
constitutionnel décide que s'il
l'utilisation combinée des procédures
mises en oeuvre à revêtu un caractère
inhabituel en réponse aux conditions du
débat elle n'a pas eu pour effet de
rendre la procédure législative
contraire à la Constitution en revanche
et ça c'était prévisible les sages sont
censurés 6 articles l'index seniors le
CDI senior la visite médicale de fin de
carrière pour juger de la pénibilité il
considère que ce sont des cavalier c'est
à dire des choses qui n'avaient pas
d'incidence sur les contes de la
sécurité sociale ça Myriam c'était censé
être un peu le sucré de la réforme et
puis vous l'avez dit je reviendrai dans
quelques minutes pour les détailler mais
donc le référendum d'initiative partagée
cette proposition a été retoquée par les
sages voilà donc le bilan pour la
première ministre qui twitch le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé ton sur le fond
que sur la procédure la réforme conforme
à notre Constitution le texte arrive à
la fin de son processus démocratique ce
soir il n'y a ni vainqueur ni vaincu
mais même je vous laisse avec vos
invités voir si certains ont le
sentiment d'être gagnant ou d'être
perdants de ces décisions merci beaucoup
Elsa et à tout à l'heure c'était limpide
j'ai commencé avec vous Nicolas mesdor
bon ni vainqueur ni vaincu ça s'appelle
un peu des éléments de langage soulagés
quand même j'imagine quand on est dans
la majorité ce soir
oui et non je partage assez l'analyse de
la première ministre déjà on peut se
satisfaire qu'effectivement en soi à la
fin du processus démocratique sur la
réforme des retraites bien évidemment on
salue que le fait que le Conseil
constitutionnel est validé l'âge de
départ à la retraite cependant comme la
très bien dit votre collègue voilà il y
a aussi l'index senior qui est
malheureusement n'est pas retenu pour
cause de non constitutionnalités et je
crois mais ça fait quand même un texte
un peu différent ce soir
tout de même en tout cas ça nous ça va
nous forcer ça va nous nous inciter à
travailler sur une future loi travail
qui va devoir prendre en compte tout
toutes ces mesures qui ont été rejetées
par le Conseil ne va pas s'arrêter là on
sera à l'hôtel de ville tout à l'heure
l'amplifie au contraire écouter le droit
de manifester et quelque chose
d'important dans la Cinquième République
les conditions que ça se déroule selon
les règles établies il n'y a pas de
souci à ce que les Français qui sont qui
soient mécantants de cette réforme
puisse continuer à montrer leur
mécontentement il y a aucun souci avec
ça ce qu'on dise juste c'est que on va
devoir travailler sur leur travail parce
que ce qu'a fait ressortir le débat sur
la retraite et vous savez même si on est
des députés de la majorité on est on est
ni sous on ni aveugle on est aussi des
députés du peuple je crois qu'on entend
le débat sur le travail sur sa
pénibilité sur le nouveau rapport qu'on
a au travail sur le fait de de le penser
pour les futurs générations je crois que
c'est quelque chose
on sait beaucoup interrogé sur l'ordre
de ces deux lois Sandrine Rousseau je
viens vers vous dans un instant mais on
va écouter les réactions de la gauche
les principaux chefs de file de la nuque
ont fait une conférence de presse juste
après la décision à l'Assemblée écoutez
si la loi est jugée constitutionnelle
cela ne change rien sur le fait que nous
pensons toujours et nous continuerons de
penser et de redire que cette loi est
injuste et inutile et après trois mois
de la mobilisation la plus puissante que
nous ayons eu depuis 50 ans dans ce pays
le blocage du pays reste après cette
décision absolument totale et l'impasse
démocratique de même vous avez vu
aujourd'hui que ça soit par bateau par
camion ou autre à chaque fois que le
Président de la République c'est
ministre sa première ministre ou les
parlementaires sortent ils sont
interpellés sur cette question et nous
le disons cette réforme des retraites va
empoisonner durablement le quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron s'il continue à
vouloir persister sur cette question
nous souhaitons que dans sa sagesse si
le président peut faire preuve une fois
dans ce quinquennat de sagesse qu'il se
rappelle de ce que fut la décision du
président Chirac sur le CPE
et qu'il s'abstiennent de promulguer le
texte validé
il peut aussi comme ça lui a été suggéré
par l'intention syndicale utiliser
l'article 10 de la Constitution puisque
une censure partielle revenir devant le
Parlement et demander à ce que le
Parlement vote sur le texte nous ne
lâcherons pas et nous ferons tout ce
qu'il faut pour que les Français et le
droit à la parole
André Renaud on vous a vu sur ces images
vous avez encore quelques leviers il y a
la manifestation c'est un droit même
c'est la loi est promulguée ça va être
compliqué quand même ce soir non pour
l'opposition c'est plus difficile non
je pense que la réforme est toujours pas
légitime politiquement en fait et c'est
ça le sujet c'est que le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé en droit en droit
pur bon il aurait pu sans doute aussi
réévaluer la force et l'importance
relative du Parlement vis-à-vis de
l'exécutif et c'est d'ailleurs parmi les
arguments qui avaient porté l'iode dans
le débat et qui était intéressant je
rappelle quand même qu'on a une réforme
des retraites sans études d'impact par
exemple ce qui a été publié l'étude
d'impact non ça n'est pas une étude
d'impact c'est un document qui a été
fait de manière volontaire par le
gouvernement sans méthodologie et qui
relevait des inégalités sur et qui
relever les inégalités bien sûr mais par
exemple on ne savait pas combien de
personnes allaient voir leur retraite
réévaluées à 1200 euros ça a fait
l'objet de bien des jours de débats dans
l'Assemblée nationale bon aujourd'hui on
a une loi qui est presque pire que celle
qui a été présentée avant le Conseil
constitutionnel mais est-ce que vous
respectez la décision déjà vous êtes élu
de la nationale et je respecte
maintenant ça ne la rend pas légitime
politiquement c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
elle est légitime sur le droit elle est
validée sur le plan du droit très bien
et ça c'est incontestable maintenant
elle n'en est pas moins illégitime sur
le plan politique elle en reste toujours
un juste toujours les aesh les
assistantes d'éducation pour les
étudiants handicapés devront toujours
faire deux ans de plus tandis que les
retraites chapeau n'ont toujours pas
contrôlés donc en fait il y a pas de
justice dans cette réforme mais alors
pas du tout du tout et le fait de rendre
donner rendez-vous dans une loi future
sur le travail ça nous convient pas non
mais on a l'impression vraiment de
quelque chose une espèce de fuite en
avant et moi j'ai été très frappée par
le fait que le Président de la
République est annoncé dès la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel qu'il
promulguerait la loi lundi alors qu'il a
invité les syndicats mardi ça veut dire
qu'en fait il continue le rapport de
force à un moment où vraiment il aurait
besoin d'entendre les syndicats vous lui
demandez d'attendre et aujourd'hui il a
15 jours pour promulguer par ailleurs le
groupe écologiste avec la nupes a envoyé
lui envoyer une lettre là il y a une
heure pour lui demander de se référer à
l'article 10 de la Constitution et de
repasser par le Parlement ce qui serait
une manière de remettre le demander une
nouvelle délibération devant le
Parlement même si la loi est promulguée
c'est voilà l'un des secrets de notre
Constitution Bertrand pencher sur la
ligne de la nuit pas ce soir je rappelle
quand même pour mon téléspectateurs que
votre groupe d'ordinaire est plutôt
placé au centre de l'hémicycle
absolument absolument écoutez moi je
suis ce soir très triste et même très en
colère il reste de cette mesure de cette
de cette de cette ex que des mesures les
plus injustes la motion de censure a
failli passer à nevoit près je peux vous
dire que si c'est ce texte là avait été
présenté tel qu'il est maintenant
l'émotion de censure serait passée et le
gouvernement aurait été renversé j'ai
discuté avec certains parlementaires y
compris de LR en disant si on avait su
on serait venu voter la motion de
censure
qui n'avaient pas de l'objectif
financiers donc ils allaient être
retoqué
compte tenu de la composition du Conseil
constitutionnel qui est tout sauf une
cour constitutionnelle l'humiliation sur
évidemment politique avec bon trois
tiers nommé par le Président de la
République quand il parle le président
du Sénat tire par le président de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a 4 anciens
ministres où ils font ils font
correctement
les conclusions ne sont même pas rendues
sont même pas rendus publics moi j'en
appelle d'ailleurs une réforme du
Conseil
constitutionnalités de la décision pour
vous c'est quand même une accusation
très grave
je rappelle la constitution du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est pas une cour
constitutionnelle c'est pas une cour
constitutionnelle ils rendent des
décisions juridiques mais aussi les
décisions politiques ont dû d'ailleurs
des tas de décision politique dans le
passé dans le passé on sait comme ça
ceci dit un la crise sociale de la crise
démocratique et maintenant la crise
institutionnelle je vous garantis que ça
fait beaucoup dans une France dont on
dit être maintenant le qui sont faibles
de l'Union européenne pour son
instabilité démocratique il y a beaucoup
de sujets parce que ça monte beaucoup
sur la critique du Conseil conditionnel
sur sa politique déjà votre regard sur
cette décision écoutez le Conseil
constitutionnel en effet ça n'est pas
une cour constitutionnelle comme long
nous a mis allemand ou c'est le
Bundestag qui désigne des juristes qui
représentent la palette des opinions
juridiques de la société allemande nous
c'est en effet une institution politique
qui juge à la fois en droit et en
opportunité politique mais ça ça veut
dire quoi parce que les Français
comprennent mal ça veut dire que ils
tiennent compte de circonstances ce que
font d'ailleurs toujours les juristes
quand ils interprètent un texte de droit
il n'y a pas le droit c'est pas quelque
chose qui vous tombe dessus c'est comme
ça c'est pas comme ça c'est tout l'art
du droit c'est d'interpréter les choses
à la lumière de ce que ce serait la
société autour de soi il l'ont fait ce
soir et ils l'ont fait dans un texte moi
je n'ai que le communiqué de presse pour
le moment ils ont pas avoir mis leur
commentaire en ligne je crois à cette
heure-ci mais il répond pour un par
point à toutes les à tous les points de
la saisine dont il a été l'objet et il
répond clairement c'est une position
juridique franchement il y en a d'autres
j'ai des collègues professeurs de droit
qui pensent que le véhicule législatif
comme on dit utilisé la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ça
suffisait à retoquer le texte il montre
comment non selon eux c'est une
procédure tout à fait constitutionnelle
il n'y a pas besoin de circonstances
exceptionnelles pour s'en servir c'est
normal il disparaît pour les procédures
à même dire
Rousseau oui pareil pour les délais donc
on a laissé au Parlement pareil pour la
sincérité des débats les règlements tel
qu'ils ont été appliqués à l'Assemblée
au Sénat il valide tout et il valide 12
juridiquement
moi je suis de ceux qui ne sont pas
satisfaits de la façon dont fonctionne
le conseil depuis 1958 mais qu'est-ce
que vous voulez pour le moment
il dit le droit constitutionnel et donc
justement on va voir la
compositions politiques et sociaux ça a
été de dire quoi qu'ils disent on sera
bien forcé d'accepter cette décision je
crois que ça c'est aussi un élément
d'apaisement dans une démocratie on est
déjà sur la question
les politiques sont formidables mais les
syndicats aussi pour anticiper des
choses dont ils savent que ça n'arrivera
pas
le texte va être promulgué dans 48
heures par le chef de l'État il n'y a
pas de discussion là-dessus il l'a
toujours annoncé il va le faire
il y a pas de discussion possible il va
le faire on le sait tous il va le faire
il y aura pas de nouvelles
il y aura pas de nouvelles délibération
de la loi on le sait parfaitement donc
il faut se projeter dans l'avenir
politique
puis finalement montre qu'il est plus
attentif aux besoins de la monarchie
présidentielle qui assure du peuple
souverain la lutte continue doit
rassembler ses forces on ira d'ailleurs
dans un tout petit instant place de
l'Hôtel de Ville qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez dire vous le professeur de droit
public sur cette institution pour
convaincre les Français qu'elle est
utile et qu'elle était impartiale et
indépendante c'est pas mon rôle de
convaincre les Français qu'elle est
utile
je ne sais pas j'ai une opinion sur le
personnel sur le Conseil consiste
cette institution est inchangé depuis
1958 dans sa composition grosso modo il
y a désormais une audition qui est
organisée pour les membres mais depuis
1958 c'est la même composition et on a
toujours ce débat récurrent sur les
modifications de sa composition je
rappelle qu'il y a aussi des membres de
droits donc tout le monde est d'accord
je parle sous votre contrôle mesdames et
messieurs et députés pour qu'ils ne
viennent plus au Conseil président de la
République François
malgré les différents projets de réforme
qui ont été mis en oeuvre et tout
interprétation qu'elle soit juridique ou
pas à une part de subjectivité en
elle-même alors pour limiter
subjectivité en droit il y a des
garde-fous ces garde-fous c'est la
jurisprudence antérieure en la matière
il y en avait pas beaucoup voire peu et
l'autre garde-fou c'est la collégialité
et le problème du Conseil consuel s'il y
en a un c'est que cette collégialité
elle est pas synonyme de diversité elle
est passionnante de diversité dans la
composition du conseil consuel je vais
citer un de mes collègues pour pas
prendre position personnelle qui
s'appelle Patrick vaxman qui était
professeur Université de Strasbourg à
propos des nominations qui ont lieu qui
ont eu lieu l'année dernière il a dit
que ces trois nominations étaient je le
cite plus que médiocre c'est pas moi
c'est lui et donc il y a de ce point de
vue on va pas citer nos mémoire
pour des règles incertains pour dire que
les modalités de domination les choix
qui sont faits ne reflètent pas la
diversité à la fois homme femme jeune
vieux ou vieille à la fois des positions
politiques des positions syndicales
philosophiques c'est le péché originel
de la composition du conseil consuel et
il appart aux autorités de le dire en
tout cas c'est l'institution garante de
la constitutionnalité de nos lois en
5ème république bonsoir Stéphanie
Despierre pardonnez-moi d'avoir été un
peu longue quel est l'ambiance quelle
est l'atmosphère autour de vous et dans
quel état d'esprit sont les manifestants
place de l'hôtel de ville après cette
décision
écoutez Myriam depuis une trentaine de
minutes la place de l'hôtel de ville
c'est clairement vidé les manifestants
se sont répartis dans les rues
adjacentes le cortège se dirige à priori
vers la place de la Bastille via la rue
de Rivoli rue de Rivoli alors à 18h
quand l'annonce du Conseil
constitutionnel est tombé on a entendu
ici une clameur de protestation la place
était beaucoup plus remplie mais loin
d'être pleine les manifestants ici
n'étaient pas surpris ils s'attendait à
cette décision contraire à leurs
espérances
je ne suis pas étonné le Conseil
constitutionnel de toute façon la
plupart du temps vote comme on l'attend
avec le gouvernement en place et en
l'occurrence avec notre gouvernement de
droite c'est une déception dans le sens
on peut pas s'attendre à grand chose
d'autre de la composition politique du
Conseil à l'heure actuelle on dirait que
c'est une question de juridique et de
droit il y a quand même des conditions
qui auraient pu faire qu'on aurait pu
voter contre le refus de du référendum
d'initiative partagée je trouve ça assez
là pour le coup je suis déçu parce qu'il
y avait pas de raison juridique
particulière de le refuser ça nous
oblige en fait à
monter en pression de toutes les
manières possibles
parce que les institutions refusent
d'entendre notre colère
alors tout à l'heure sur la place il y a
beaucoup de jeunes d'étudiants des
couples aussi un peu plus âgés et bien
évidemment les syndicats on écoute la
réaction de Sophie Binet la nouvelle
patronne de la CGT qui appelle à la
mobilisation nous appelons le président
de la République a retrouvé la sagesse à
faire preuve d'écoute et à comprendre ce
qui se passe dans le pays et à ne pas
promulguer cette loi Emmanuel Macron ne
peut pas continuer à diriger le pays
s'il ne retire pas cette réforme pour
permettre d'apaiser et de retrouver la
voix du dialogue l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales elle donne
rendez-vous à l'ensemble des Françaises
et des Français le 1er mai pour une
mobilisation exceptionnelle inédite pour
un raz-de-marais populaire pour gagner
le retrait de cette réforme des
retraites et la mise à l'ordre du jour
de perspective de progrès social et la
CGT elle appelle également les salariés
à continuer à se mobiliser à continuer à
faire grève à agir en multipliant les
initiatives et les actions dès ce soir
et donc au 1er mai
le président de la République avait
proposé au syndicat une rencontre mardi
mais pour l'instant l'intersey syndicale
explique quel refuse de s'asseoir à la
table des discussions avant le 1er mai
Nicolas metdorf merci beaucoup Stéphanie
Despierre vous l'entendez Sophie Binet
de la CGT ce soir l'intersyndical est
uni Laurent Berger de la CFDT aussi pour
dire ne promulguez pas Emmanuel Macron
en tout cas pas trop vite pas dans deux
jours ça vous entendez ça est-ce que
vous vous êtes sensible vous dites comme
Laurent Carole de toute façon c'est plié
et on l'entend souvent et d'ailleurs mes
collègues ici le rappel souvent aussi
dans l'hémicycle donc on entend les
choses
on vous écoute beaucoup mais vous savez
pas l'impression que ça cabrerait encore
plus le mouvement social qu'on
basculerait peut-être dans des blocages
dans des choses beaucoup plus dures si
le texte est promulgué rapidement
le processus a été démocratique nous
avons fait campagne sur un âge de départ
à la retraite à 65 ans à 65 ans le
président de la République est arrivé en
tête au premier tour puis a gagné au
deuxième tour nous l'avons toujours
assumé nous avons entendu le mouvement
social puisque nous avons baissé l'âge
de départ à 64 ans dès le début nous
avons pris en compte plusieurs
amendements plusieurs réflexions sur la
pénibilité du travail donc le processus
démocratique a duré un certain temps
quasiment 200 heures de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale on a à
l'opposition de la réforme est encore
plus fort de 11 points on est on a
utilisé le 49-3 conformément la
Constitution monsieur le Président du
Groupe lot a déposé une motion de
censure qui n'est pas passée donc il y a
eu un vote à l'Assemblée nationale le
processus est démocratique on peut pas
dire le contraire
j'entends les critiques sur le Conseil
constitutionnel mais si le Conseil
constitutionnel avait choisi de ne pas
valider la loi est-ce qu'on aurait eu
les mêmes critiques de la part des
l'opposition et des syndicats non parce
que ça existe comme c'est comme ça
depuis 1958 donc on entend les choses et
c'est pour ça que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que il faut désormais travailler
sur une loi de travail pour récupérer
par le Conseil constitutionnel et encore
améliorer les choses pour l'instant la
main tendue du président avenir mardi
n'est pas n'est pas saisi par les
syndicats alors qu'on découvre en direct
et on les a vu tout à l'heure les images
de cette manifestation de l'Hôtel de
Ville voilà qui se déplace dans les rues
adjacentes et qui et qui est dans les le
quartier du Marais dans le dans le
quatrième Sandrine Rousseau voilà la
main tendue maintenant c'est on passe à
autre chose pour parler des vrais sujets
sur le train non non je sais que c'est
votre espoir mais non nous ne passerons
pas à autre chose et alors là clairement
pas pourquoi parce que je ne peux pas
laisser dire que la réforme est
démocratique je peux dire qu'elle a été
constitutionnelle mais je ne peux pas
dire qu'elle respecte l'esprit de la
démocratie qui est la cinquième
république avec un parlement j'ai envie
de vous dire
Parlement on a l'impression que ça vous
gêne faites des 49-3 sur des 49-3 et
puis supprimer cette instance scanner
uniquement de vous faire perdre du temps
et au moins ça sera clair et par
ailleurs il y a une deuxième chose qui
moi me frapper énormément dans la
politique qui est menée et par le
gouvernement et par Emmanuel Macron
c'est à quel point les contre-pouvoirs
sont systématiquement attaqués en tant
que contre-pouvoir et là en même temps
que Elisabeth borne disait qu'il n'y
avait pas de vainqueurs et pas de vaincu
dans un tweet elle disait une heure
avant que le corps donc le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites allait être
refondé parce que c'est de sa faute si
les Français n'avaient pas compris la
réforme des retraites mais ça va en fait
on a très bien compris
son président du corps à l'Assemblée
nationale le corps a fait un travail
plus réaliste d'évaluation des scénarios
donc en fait le on a l'impression que le
macronisme est dans une espèce de folie
où il ne peut même plus entendre la
critique de contre-pouvoir
et de contre-pouvoir historique comme le
sont les syndicats ou comme les le corps
sur les retraites mais comme les LDH et
comme les pleins d'autres organismes
l'IRSN là ça fait une attaque en règle
de l'ensemble des contre-pouvoirs dès
lors qu'ils contreviennent ou dès lors
qu'ils aimaient des critiques à
l'endroit de la politique qui est
monnaie nous ne sommes enfin vraiment
c'est un danger démocratique je le dis
et là la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel a donné un pouvoir qui
me semble être exorbitant à l'exécutif
vis-à-vis du parlementaire bon on entend
voilà le risque d'un d'une crise
démocratique profonde Bertrand recherche
vous redonne la parole dans un instant
mais priorité aux réactions on est avec
le président du groupe socialiste Boris
Vallot depuis sa circonscription des
Landes bonsoir première réaction ce soir
surpris déçu par cette décision et ce
rejet du Rip est la validation de
l'essentiel de la réforme
évidemment d'abord une grande déception
grande déception pour pour les Français
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle il va leur
falloir travailler deux ans de plus si
le président de la République s'obstine
et promulgue cette loi c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle aussi pour le
Parlement ça a été dit sur votre plateau
le Conseil constitutionnel a validé une
forme de démocratie expéditive un
véhicule juridique qui est parfaitement
contestable dans ces intentions de cours
tournaient le débat le débat
parlementaire et puis voilà ce n'est pas
la fin du processus du processus
démocratique nous avons vécu une
séquence où les institutions ont été
brutalisées les partenaires sociaux ont
été méprisés les Français n'ont pas été
écoutés alors qu'ils ont une aspiration
à une forme de démocratie continue parce
qu'il se souviennent des circonstances
dans lesquelles le président de la
République a été élu disait d'ailleurs à
l'époque que cela l'obligeait on a
compris depuis lors que ça l'obligeait
rien du tout donc évidemment nous allons
continuer de nous battre voilà comment
précisément qu'est-ce que vous demandez
une nouvelle délibération il va y avoir
un deuxième référendum vous y croyez la
première des choses que nous demandons
président de la République c'est le
retrait de sa réforme de ne pas
promulguer cette loi sinon il y a
effectivement d'autres possibilités
constitutionnelles l'article 10 pour
délibérer à nouveau parce que je vous
rappelle que jamais l'Assemblée
nationale n'aura voté ce texte ce texte
n'est pas couvert d'une onction
démocratique il y a la possibilité du
référendum d'initiative partagée une
deuxième formulation a été proposée au
Conseil constitutionnel nous en
attendons le résultat nous avons aussi
proposé de déposer une loi d'abrogation
de la mesure d'âge c'est-à-dire du
passage à 64 ans si le président de la
République devait s'obstiner mais vous
voyez bien que ce qui se joue est une
crise sociale plus profonde que la seule
réforme des retraites est désormais une
crise institutionnelle et démocratique
extrêmement extrêmement profonde et je
crois que l'apaisement la concorde
civile la cohésion nationale la défense
aussi de ce que nous avons en commun que
la raison forte et que le Président de
la République retire cette réforme il y
perd beaucoup plus que ce qu'il pense y
gagner bon merci beaucoup Boris Vallot
pour cette réaction ce soir Bertrand
pencher vous vous avez manifesté je ne
crois pas
la première fois de ma vie
sans qu'il odeur de merguez la bière
que les la gauche parlementaires de la
nuque va continuer à battre le pavé même
promul ce week-end vous le groupe liotte
va continuer à appeler les Français à
battre le pavé
je suis à 7 heures à ces désespéré
j'observe d'année en année un
affaiblissement notre démocratie je me
demande si le seul bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron en fin de mandat ça sera pas
d'avoir remis les clés du camion à
l'extrême droite enfin on se rend pas
compte de la situation du pays quoi on
écoute pas le peuple bon c'est pas la
première fois n'écoute pas les corps
intermédiaires c'est pas la première
fois on n'écoute pas le Parlement c'est
pas la première fois bon on demande un
référendum c'est prévu on n'en tient pas
compte bon partage la vie de Roland
Cayrol et Paul Cassia va constitution
elle est comme ça quoi mais franchement
ça devrait inspirer le président de la
République à de la responsabilité dans
une affaire comme ça
quel bilan 2027 bon je vous donne la
parole mais c'est toujours la place de
l'hôtel de ville avec cette fois-ci Eric
Coquerel apparemment ça commence un peu
à chauffer autour de vous Marco pommier
c'est à VOUS pas toujours cette fois-ci
oui Myriam alors on est plus vraiment
sur la place de l'hôtel de ville puisque
on a suivi en fait les manifestants dans
le cortège spontané qui s'est improvisé
on est donc avec
Eric Coquerel député la France insoumise
monsieur Coquerel quel est votre
réaction ce soir est-ce que vous êtes
déçu de cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel je suis déçu voilà déçu
parce que sur le papier il y avait tout
pour que cette loi soit rotoquée je
continue à le considérer pas surpris
parce que malheureusement le conseiller
constituel a aussi
c'est pas juste des gens dans un bocal
qu'on sort et qui prennent ici objectifs
ils ont à passer politique et autres et
je m'attendais à malheureusement à cette
décision politique pour vous il y a un
côté politique y compris dans le fait
d'avoir roté les cavaliers qui étaient
les seuls arguments soit disant sociaux
pour cette loi bon donc voilà on est là
je pense que ça va du coup il y a la
crise sociale elle reste c'est-à-dire la
loi n'a pas de légitimité la crise
politique Macron n'a pas de majorité et
maintenant il y a une crise de régime
qui s'accentue parce que les gens vont
les gens vont les gens vont être
accentués de ce point de vue là
les gens vont être restés là rester là
les gens vont être ça va s'accentuer et
je crois que ça va assez Macron et pas
sorti de l'auberge pour aller vite nous
en tout cas on va continuer la bataille
merci beaucoup
Eric Coquerel des syndicats merci
Monsieur Coquerel et on est obligé de
d'arrêter ce direct car les CRS sont en
train d'intervenir dans le cortège
actuellement merci beaucoup Marco
pommier Roland Carole crise de régime
crise politique crise institutionnelle
on en est là il y a un petit peu de tout
ça bien sûr
je voudrais dire trois petites choses la
première
le 49-3 c'est comme un balader
49 3 c'est un instrument de la Cinquième
République qui a été inventé non
seulement par les gaullistes mais par
les anciens présidents de la 4ème
République pour instituer ce qu'ils
appelaient un parlementarisme
rationalisé l'idée c'est que un
gouvernement dit au Parlement là je vous
propose un texte qui est absolument
essentiel pour moi il fait partie de mon
ADN
jour où vous prenez mon texte et vous me
gardez vous voulez pas de montrer que
c'est vous me virez moi je trouve ça une
solution démocratique au conflit entre
exécutif et législation
a été rejetée la démocratie a été
effectuée
je vous rappelle je disais du bien de de
l'institutions allemandes tout à l'heure
je fais remarquer que dans l'article 67
de la loi fondamentale allemande les
règles de la notion de censure sont les
mêmes avec majorité absolue des membres
composant l'assemblée et ils ajoutent il
faut se mettre d'accord à l'avant sur le
nom du prochain
on est quand même loin des
méthodes dictatoriales deuxièmement je
trouve l'interdiction des cavaliers
quelque chose d'un peu cavalier dans le
droit public français je vois pas
pourquoi le Parlement peut pas
travailler comme il veut je vois pas
pourquoi un conseil constitutionnel dit
ça ça n'a rien à voir dans le texte
c'est une Paris juridique française
vous avez
finances et que là ce sont des mesures
qui nous paraît budgétaires
pourquoi pourquoi le Parlement à mon
avis devrait pouvoir légiférer comme ils
l'entend s'il veut des contreparties qui
l'inscrit dans la loi je vois pas
pourquoi on dit c'est pas constitué
enjamber tout ça c'est que parce que
vous parliez de crise sociale je crois
que nous souffrons dans ce pays d'être
le seul pays européen qui ne pratique
pas la négociation sociale au niveau
national le seul Emmanuel Macron a
théorisé malheureusement là-dessus sur
le fait que les syndicats étaient
indispensables efficaces dans
l'entreprise dans les branches mais que
c'était quelque chose qui mettait le
désordre au niveau national qui
empêchait le progrès franchement ça se
passe ça je crois que il est obligé
d'entrer dans une politique pour les
prochains textes sociaux de
co-construction avec les forces
syndicales qui ont montré là leur
caractère à la fois raisonnable efficace
et populaire la démocratie sociale c'est
un mot qu'on utilise très très peu en
France on en parle beaucoup depuis la
crise des retraites mais qu'est-ce que
c'est et pourquoi il faudrait au fond
qu'elle existe davantage bon d'abord
elle est inscrite cette démocratie
sociale dans notre Constitution à
l'article premier de la Constitution qui
dit que la France est une République
entre autres sociales et par ailleurs on
a un texte magnifique dans le préambule
de la Constitution qui est la
déclaration de 1946 la déclaration du
Préambule de la Constitution de 1946 qui
prévoit l'implication des représentants
et représentants du monde du travail
dans tout ce qui est prise de décision
relativement aux conditions aux
conditions de travail mais il reste que
la loi est faite par le Parlement et que
cette ce processus législatif n'implique
pas que les organisations syndicales
soient consultées de manière obligatoire
de manière à ce leur décision s'impose
c'est le les parlementaires qui font la
loi la difficulté de cette loi qui est
donc validée par le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est qu'elle concentre
tous les mécanismes du parlementarisme
rationalisé dans une période très très
courte de temps c'est presque
caricatural on a tous on a tout eu et le
Conseil consuel en validant ce processus
renforce a été dit renforce c'est vrai
on peut pas le contester objectivement
l'exécutif par rapport au Parlement et
donc accroît ce déséquilibre qu'on peut
critiquer ou approuver mais il y a un
déséquilibre au profit de l'exécutif
en l'occurrence on peut se demander si
ce déséquilibre est pas un peu daté je
rappelle ce pinceau le contrôle de mon
voisin que le Président de la République
a été élu mais c'est vrai que c'était en
2017 sur la promesse d'un changement des
pratiques d'un changement institution
nouvelle méthode est-ce que
s'en tenir alors justement 58 c'est pas
un tout petit peu anachronique c'est
l'objet il est 20h05 de cette deuxième
partie de débat redonner la parole au
peuple
la respiration démocratique on va
s'attarder à présent sur le rip la
demande de référendum d'initiative
partagée qui a été rejeté pour des
raisons d'y recevabilité formelle on
voit tout cela avec Elsa mundingava que
l'on retrouve tout de suite
vous en avez déjà parlé avec vos invités
le rip référendum d'initiative partagée
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'avant que les Français puissent
répondre à une question posée par cette
initiative il faut vraiment remplir tout
un tas d’étapes c'est assez compliqué la
première c'est de réunir un certain
nombre de parlementaires ça c'est bon la
deuxième c'est que le Conseil est
constitutionnel juge la question
conforme et là le conseil à ticket
pourquoi parce qu'à la date
d'enregistrement de la saisine la
proposition de loi visant à affirmer que
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite ne
peut être fixé au lac 62 ans n'emporte
pas de changement dans l'état du droit
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle c'est encore
62 ans dès lors ce que disent les sages
du Conseil constitutionnel c'est que
cette proposition ne porte pas au sens
de l'article 11 de la Constitution sur
une réforme relative à la politique
sociale alors ça les oppositions à
gauche l'avait un petit peu anticipé
puisqu'elles ont déposé une deuxième
proposition de référendum d'initiative
partagée mais attention il y a toujours
cette mention au 62 ans dans la nouvelle
version mais il y a un article
supplémentaire sur le financement de la
mesure les oppositions croise les doigts
est-ce que ça suffira à faire changer
d'avis les sages et bien rebelote on
attend la décision cette fois ce sera le
3 mai prochain évidemment on suit ça
avec attention merci beaucoup alors
Nicolas
metzdorf vous personnellement vous vous
sentez quand même ce besoin cette envie
des Français d'être consulté au-delà de
chaque quinquennat et là ça sera pas
possible vous personnellement s'il y
avait un rythme qui avait au bout vous y
seriez favorable ou pas vous avez peur
du Rip ou pas vous savez vous parlez à
un néocalédonien
qui a vécu trois référendum
donc les référendums on en a pas peur
ça a l'avantage de donner la parole au
peuple et quand on est un parlementaire
on n'a pas peur de donner la parole au
peuple
il y a une chose qui il faut aussi
prendre en compte et nous on l'a
constaté aussi chez nous c'est que
l'avantage d'un parlement de responsable
politique qui s'affrontent c'est que
c'est ça sert aussi d'exutoire
c'est-à-dire que tu es français se
reconnaissent en nous et
c'est nous finalement qui clivons le
débat quand c'est un référendum c'est
les citoyens qui s'affrontent chez eux
dans leur famille dans leur cercles
d'amitié lors de campagne donc c'est
aussi quelque chose qui qui peut amener
une certaine tension qui peut
redescendre dans la société française
alors qu'aujourd'hui elle est exacerbée
par le pouvoir politique ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que dans une
dans une situation comme la nôtre
aujourd'hui dans le cas d'une majorité
relative
l'attitude des oppositions est
importante elle n'est plus comme dans un
système de majorité absolue l'opposition
à une responsabilité aussi et je trouve
que
certains leaders d'opposition alimentent
le chaos il faut faire attention
précisément
c'est pas mon propos non mais je veux
pas c'est des questions de fond que l'on
pose et quand on remet en cause tout le
temps nos institutions en participant à
la défiance de la population
je suis très content d'avoir entendu
madame mousso tout à l'heure dire le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est prévu par
notre Constitution il faut le respect ça
c'est une parole responsable je le dis
je le dis quand on dit que Emmanuel
Macron doit absolument retirer sa
réforme
il a été élu là-dessus on a reculé d'un
ange de départ en tête et il ne va pas
la retirer par contre il fait des
ouvertures sur une proposition de loi
ensuite qui va pouvoir amener et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut être responsable
c'est savoir réceptionner cette matière
on a bien compris que il se projette
dans l'avenir déjà Sandrine Rousseau
déjà moi deuxième déception ce soir oui
c'est une grande déception parce que je
pense que ça aurait été un moyen de
donner la voix au peuple et de donner
aussi une forme de débouché politique à
cette espèce de de sentiment qui monte
je pense très fortement dans le peuple
français et qu'on devrait analyser bien
plus que nous ne le faisons qui est
cette espèce de colère sans déboucher
parce qu'en fait quand j'entends qu'il y
a une main tentue il n'y en a pas il n'y
en a pas et enfin vraiment il faut
assister au débat parlementaire pour
voir à quel point soit ça passe selon le
texte prévu par le gouvernement soit ça
ne passe pas et c'est un 49-3 en fait
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas d'espace
créé par le gouvernement pour discuter
des textes et pour essayer de trouver
des compromis le déboucher politique
c'est la prochaine présidentielle elle
l'a même tweeté on le verra tout à
l'heure on peut en parler parce que
précisément un le rassemblement national
ne sait pas opposé à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle au texte au texte et
vraiment là-dessus il faudra quand même
décrypter les votes qu'ils ont eu mais
en plus on déposé quand même la bataille
n'est pas terminée la bataille la
bataille n'est pas terminée et vraiment
je voudrais dire que il y a quand même
là quelque chose qui ne va pas dans ce
qu'on appelle une démocratie aujourd'hui
mais qui s'appelle la Cinquième
République telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est un homme contre tout un peuple
contre les corps intermédiaires contre
le Parlement et un homme seul qui décide
et là vraiment on est à la limite de ce
que peut-être une démocratie et à la
limite de ce qu'est notre cinquième
république et il nous faut vraiment
penser la sixième notamment sur la base
d'un renforcement du référendum c'est
pour ça que j'espère que le second
référendum va être validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel je trouve et je termine
là-dessus que l'argument donné pour
sortir le premier référendum ne peut pas
être utilisé en état pour le second
référendum puisqu'il y a un second
article c'est un peu technique mais il y
a un deuxième article qui pourrait être
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel je
dis au Conseil constitutionnel il y a
encore une voix de sortie par le haut de
cette affaire saisissons là c'est vrai
que les Français c'est frappant quand on
regarde toujours ce même sondage au doxa
pour Le Figaro 64 % des Français
comptent apporter leur signature si ce
cette demande de RIP était recevable
c'est potentiellement plus de 5 millions
de Français et donc au-delà des seuils
nécessaires petit mémo sur le parcours
des haies affranchir et elles sont
nombreuses le Conseil par le même d'une
procédure dissuasive avec Marco pommier
et je vous parle je vous repasse la
parole juste après
le rip s'est avant tout une course
d'obstacles plusieurs étapes il faut
d'abord réunir un cinquième du Parlement
soit 185 parlementaires le Conseil
constitutionnel doit ensuite juger la
conformité de la proposition
référendaire les Sages ont un mois pour
le faire si les conditions sont remplies
alors le compte à rebours est lancé
c'est la troisième étape réunir au moins
4,8 millions de signatures pour espérer
un référendum une procédure gravée dans
l'article 11 de la Constitution c'est
Nicolas Sarkozy qui l'a voulu en 2008
Comment le peuple souverain peut-il
prolonger sa confiance renouveler sa
confiance ou retirer sa confiance voilà
en vérité la question centrale de la
réforme des institutions de la
République un RIP pour redonner la
parole aux citoyens pourtant le
processus n'a encore jamais abouti seule
véritable tentative en 2019
sur la privatisation des aéroports de
Paris à l'époque la gauche et une partie
de la droite sa lit contre le projet du
gouvernement le rip atteint la troisième
étape du processus mais la chasse aux
signatures connaît des débuts difficiles
nous avons reçu là 253 messages de
personnes qui arrivent pas à signer en
ce moment sur le site du gouvernement il
y a deux hypothèses la première
hypothèse c'est une hypothèse
d'incompétence ou sinon c'est qu'il y a
de la mauvaise volonté après 9 mois de
mobilisation la proposition référendaire
recueille plus d'un million cent mille
signatures loin très loin des 4,7
millions requises un seuil atteignable
aujourd'hui pour la gauche sur un sujet
social aussi sensible que celui des
retraites mais attention même si 10% du
corps électoral soutenait ce RIP le
Parlement devrait encore approuver cette
consultation populaire
Roland Carole on sent tous qu'il y a une
un besoin de respiration démocratique
d'être consulté d'être associé à la
décision politique surtout dans cette
crise des retraites quand on regarde
cette procédure on se dit elle a été
pensée pour ne jamais aboutir un peu oui
je pense comme vous je les Français ils
sont très désireux de participer aux
décisions qui concernent leur avenir ou
l'avenir de leurs enfants on est comme
parents d'élèves comme membre
d'associations comme salarié on a acquis
des droits à participer en politique non
c'est la démocratie représentative avec
l'image que donne parfois du coup les
politiques d'être dans une bulle très
critiquée par par le peuple qui a envie
de parler qui a envie de faire des
référendum qui a envie de convention
citoyenne qui a envie de consultation
tout ce qu'on leur propose dans le choix
possible d'une démocratie participative
ils sont pour aussi bien au niveau local
qu'au niveau national
le risque étant on sait bien pour les
référendum que on répond pas toujours à
la question posée mais celui qui la pose
et que ça devient un plébiscite mais
enfin il y a une aspiration à cette
forme de démocratie directe
si j'avais le droit de faire un
pronostic je serai réservé sur ce que va
dire que le Conseil constitutionnel pour
ce nouveau RIP
je dirais pour deux raisons d'abord il y
a toujours l'âge de 62 ans qui est
indiqué dans un de deux articles or
c'est déjà la norme de droit donc il n'y
a pas de nouvelles normes de droit et la
deuxième chose c'est que ça propose un
mode de financement différent
qui sort de la répartition
donc il sort de la philosophie actuelle
du système de retraite français en
proposant une taxation du capital
je le crois parce que la seule chose qui
m'est étonné dans le communiqué du
Conseil constitutionnel aujourd'hui je
passe environ mes amis et les politiques
mais il parle à un moment du contenu le
Conseil constitutionnel et il dit que le
gouvernement fait cette réforme pour des
raisons à la fois démographiques
financières etc et il dit ce faisant il
a pris des mesures qui ne sont pas
inappropriés au regard de l'objectif
qu'il s'est fixé et n'a pas privé de
garantie légale les exigences
constitutionnelles
c'est quand même une façon de donner en
même temps une espèce de satisfaite au
contenu même de la loi pas seulement à
sa constitutionnellement
on acceptant une autre forme de
financement
je vous donne la parole après Paul
Castiel sur ce référendum d'initiative
partagée vous vous pensiez qu'il
pourrait être recevable finalement vous
l'espériez pas si je pensais qu'il
pouvait être soi mais je l'espérais vous
avez toute une argumentation et vous
l'avez écrit à ce sujet le second même
sort rejette
pour continuer à espérer
le second comporte deux articles l'un
qui reprend celui qui n'a pas été
accepté par le Conseil consuel et puis
un autre qui comporte des dispositions
on va dire en matière financière fiscale
qui concerne les finances publiques
alors est-ce que ça rentre dans le champ
de l'article le 11 de la Constitution il
faudra il faudra y réfléchir j'ai pas
encore mon opinion complètement arrêté
sur ce point juste un petit mot sur le
rip le rythme ne conduit pas un
référendum il a même été construit pour
ne pas conduire un référendum ça a été
dit
à la fin du processus même si on a les
quatre les presque 5 millions de
signatures il suffit que le Parlement
examine la loi pour qu'elle ne conduise
pas un référendum on sait pas très bien
ce que ça veut dire examine par exemple
porter à l'ordre du jour et c'est fini
mais avant même ce référendum il y a une
phase très importante qui est celle du
recueil des soutiens qu'on aurait pu
avoir là maintenant et cette phase très
importante on l'a eu pendant la période
ADP et je l'ai vécu concrètement puisque
je te les distances pour la
privatisation des aéroports de Paris et
cette phase de recueil des soutiens
qu'on a pas eu on n'a pas eu on a eu 1
million de soutien alors qu'il en
fallait 4,8 et bien elle a quand même
permis d'empêcher la privatisation des
aéroports de Paris pour diverses raisons
conjoncturelles et elle a eu un effet
elle permet aussi à chacune et à chacun
de s'exprimer de s'exprimer de manière
très facile il n'y a pas de référendum à
l'arrivée vous dites c'est utile
absolument absolument Nicolas metzdorf
c'est vrai qu'il faut que si le
président ne décide pas de soumettre au
référendum on peut se dire qu'il peut
pouvoir ça fait beaucoup de conditions
mais imaginons que ils soient recevable
imaginons qu'il est 5 millions de
signatures imaginons que le texte soit à
l'Assemblée au Sénat il y a un sénat de
droite qui a voté l'article 7 sur les 64
ans pourraient refuser de soumettre au
référendum où là on arrive à un moment
où forcément il faudra entendre cette
demande démocratique
les règles sont claires enfin vous savez
tout est démocratique à partir du moment
où c'est dans notre Constitution et donc
les règles sont très claires c'est à
dire que si le Parlement se saisit du
sujet
soit valide ce qui est proposé soit ne
le valide pas on n'a pas besoin d'aller
au référendum c'est on va au référendum
si le Parlement ne se saisit pas de la
question et au bout de six mois au bout
de six mois que le Parlement ne s'est
pas saisi donc de la question le
président de la République est obligé
pour le coup d'organiser le référendum
donc je suppose que si le référendum est
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel le
Parlement s'en saisirait Bertrand
pencher bon on verra bien que va-t-il se
passer maintenant vous vous êtes à la
tête d'un groupe de députés charnières
comment gouverner comment légiférer dans
un quinquennat un peu suspendu la France
est une des seules démocraties du monde
à ne décentralisée aucun pouvoir aux
collectivités aucun moyen financier
c'est un des seules rares démocraties du
monde à voir aussi peu de pouvoir au
niveau du Parlement et une rare
démocratie au monde à ne jamais donner
le pouvoir au peuple et comment
voulez-vous qu'on construisent de
l'intelligence collective dans ces
conditions c'est à désespérer quoi je
n'arrive pas à comprendre que le chef de
l'État la majorité relative tout le
monde s'accorde pas surtout parce que
sur tout ça mais mais où on veut comment
où on veut aller quoi ce qu'on va ce
qu'on va continuer dans quelles
conditions c'est pas possible donc
franchement il faut il faut s'engager
vers une réforme institutionnelle et en
attendant la réforme institutrice
pour le faire Cinquième République pour
arriver à réformer les institutions ça
reste compliqué sans majorité absolue
c'est quoi les Chinois les Russes et
tout le monde va rigoler sur
l'effondrement de l'Europe à cause de la
France qui va devenir le maillon faible
de l'Union européenne à travers
au pouvoir c'est ça qui va se passer
alors que on peut vraiment réveiller
tout le monde en associant et recréer de
l'intelligence collective à quel drame
Sandrine Rousseau il y a quelques
rendez-vous quand même à l'Elysée les
cadres de la majorité sont reçus lundi
il y a cette invitation des syndicats
mardi ce soir très clairement Isabelle
borne estime qu'il faut un temps de
décantation une période de convalescence
quand elle dit pas de vainqueur pas de
vaincu on sent bien que voilà
elle veut apaiser alors c'est vrai que
le président est un peu sur une ligne un
peu sémantique différente lui ne veut
rien lâcher je suis pas complètement
d'accord sur Elizabeth band parce que
quand elle dit le corps est responsable
de la crise et elle tend aussi les
choses et ce qui me semble très évident
là dans la situation des propos
rapporter de crise démocratique dans
lequel dans laquelle on est c'est que en
fait le c'est comme si la démocratie
française confisquait en fait le pouvoir
du peuple pendant 5 ans c'est à dire que
sur la base d'un mandat qui a été
présenté
un moment dans une des circonstances
particulières il n'y avait plus aucun
moyen aucun moyen pour le peuple de
reprendre le pouvoir qu'il a conféré à
d'autres qu'il a délégué à d'autres
pendant cinq années et en fait là on a
un sujet c'est-à-dire comment fait-on
pour faire en sorte que le peuple se
sente toujours représenté parce que une
des possibilités c'est qu'en effet les
nationalistes et les xénophobes arrivent
au pouvoir mais une autre possibilité
c'est que l'abstention explose et que
probable mais oui et que devient une
démocratie s'il n'y a pas une base de
vote suffisante pour la légitimer d'une
certaine manière et là je crois que on
le pouvoir en place ne comprend pas que
l'issue de cette crise ne peut être que
mauvaise c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
avoir le sentiment de gagner dans
l'instant mais ils perdront sur le sur
la durée et ça s'appelle vraiment une
victoire à la Pyrrhus donc vraiment je
les alerte en disant que certes ils
veulent que que leur honneur soit
préservé mais qu'il pense aussi que leur
nom soit préservé dans l'histoire et
leur nom ne sera préservé que s'ils ne
font pas arriver ni les xénophobes ni
une abstention telle que en tout cas le
rassemblement national n'est pas présent
sur ce plateau c'est le premier groupe
en nombre de députés dans l'opposition à
au groupe Renaissance et au camp des
manuel Macron regardait le tweet de
Marine Le Pen s'il a décision du Conseil
constitutionnel clos la séquence
institutionnelle le sort politique de la
réforme des retraites n'est pas sceller
le peuple ayant toujours le dernier mot
il lui appartiendra de préparer
l'alternance qui reviendra sur cette
réforme inutile et injuste la
porte-parole Laure La Valette ne dit pas
autre chose écoutez
on propose évidemment c'est de respecter
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
nous sommes des républicains évidemment
et la question ne se pose pas c'est une
instance où on ne peut pas faire appel
maintenant je dis aux Français il y a un
espoir une solution évidemment c'est le
bulletin de vote c'est de faire gagner
Marine Le Pen en 2027 parce qu'elle
détricotera une fois arrivé au pouvoir
cette réforme des retraites maintenant
cette séquence institutionnelle pour
cette réforme des retraites s'arrête et
je pense qu'il y a une autre séquence
politique qui est celle évidemment des
prochaines élections
alors Roland Carole le débouché
politique il y a un mouvement social qui
a pas dit son dernier mot tout de même
61% des Français estiment qu'il faut
après la validation du texte par le
Conseil constitutionnel continuer à
battre le pavé et continuer le mouvement
social qui ont jamais changé dans les
sondages depuis trois mois c'est à peu
près 70% des Français franchement
hostiles à la réforme et à peu près 70%
des Français convaincus que la réforme
serait obligée et appliqué juste donc il
y a de la colère mais il y a aussi
résignation une espèce de fatalisme
devant ce qui nous arrive c'est la
huitième réforme des retraites on a été
contre les 8 sauf celle de Touraine qui
est passé son grand problème mais les 7
autres il y a eu des manifestations
bien sûr madame panot le sait pas parce
qu'elle est trop jeune en politique mais
il y avait beaucoup plus de monde en 95
ou en 2010 il y avait même en 95 je ne
joyeuseté de joyeuseté incroyable de la
société française à s'entraider parce
que le pays était vraiment à l'arrêt
bref c'est toujours comme ça mais mais
voilà je crois que
le vrai débouché c'est pas pour aller
dans le sens de Madame Le Pen mais d'une
certaine façon c'est de toute façon 2027
parce que dans le texte de la loi que
vous avez considéré comme un considéré
comme adopté il est prévu une clause de
revoyure en 2027 à 63 ans et on sera à
63 ans à ce moment-là et à mon avis il y
a pas que Madame Le Pen qui voudra
remettre en chantier la retraite à mon
avis tous les candidats présidentielles
vont avoir des propositions pour dire
ben ça va mieux y compris un Édouard
Philippe par exemple je le crois je le
crois je crois que le candidat du bloc
central finalement s'ils ont dégagé je
crois qu'il va se dire voilà on va pas
repartir avec ça c'est et peut-être
ça le le moment où les uns et les autres
vont découvrir qu'on peut faire
autrement
comment comment vous allez au fond
relancer ce quinquennat vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on coulisse on parle
d'une chiracisation
du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron ce qui
veut dire un peu condamné à
l'immobilisme
il y a des bons côtés au chiracisme mais
certainement pas l'immobilisme
non mais enfin pour nous vous savez les
choses sont très simples
je veux bien que l'opposition alimente
un petit peu la colère des Français sur
cette opposition de retraite mais nous
on va dérouler notre
programmeités
sur tous les deux vous avez nous en tant
la main à tout le monde sauf au plus
extrême ceux qui veulent travailler avec
nous les majorités d'idées qui peuvent
se dégager à l'Assemblée la première
ministre franchement l'agenda
parlementaire va rétrécir et qu'on peut
faire les choses par décret par
règlement
à l'Assemblée nationale et il y en a
plusieurs pardon excusez-moi mais les
énergies renouvelables qu'on a voté sont
passées par exemple 149 fois il y a des
majorités d'idées tout le temps à
l'Assemblée nationale alors on parle de
ce qui ne va pas on parle de ce qui
Clive parce que ça fait vendre ça fait
regarder la télévision
vous savez là encore je suis désolé je
prends l'exemple de mon territoire mais
nous on est en proportionnelle intégrale
on n'a jamais connu la majorité absolue
oui on fonctionne comme majorité
relative tout le temps vous avez la
culture du compromis mais le compromis
est nécessaire et je crois que ça fait
du bien à la France de retrouver
le compromis faites-le
mais non vous ne le demandez pas mais il
faut que vous soyez aussi responsable
non le compromis de ce qu'on veut c'est
un compromis où nous acceptons vos
textes en fait non il y a quand même
quelque chose de l'ordre dans un
compromis il y a chacun qui a proposé le
développement des une énergie
renouvelable le groupe écologiste ne le
vote pas vous avez trois EDL dont les
énergies renouvelables très bien donc
vous avez les premiers mots qui vous
concerne le plus donc vous aurez aussi
que vous soyez responsable vous aurez
insatisfait site du groupe Renaissance
vous avez placé les bons EDF très bien
vous êtes un bon élève c'est parfait
maintenant je vous dis un truc c'est que
on ne peut pas dire qu'on est dans la
culture du compromis en utilisant 49,3
sur 49-3 sur 49,3 dans allez de ne pas
rechercher de cours ça tombe bien
Elisabeth borne
Elisabeth borne si elle reste à Matignon
a promis de ne plus utiliser le 49-3
soft texte budgétaire Paul Cassia
c'était politiquement opportun c'était
nécessaire apparemment ça n'a pas
forcément plus au président de la
République mais de fait en dehors des
textes budgétaires le gouvernement a
droit un 49-3 de sorte qu'elle s'est
engagée entre guillemets à ne pas
utiliser un 49-3 après cette évidemment
à l'opinion publique au parlementaire
apprécié cette position mais bon une
promesse peut peut-être défaite en cas
de circonstances particulières Roland
Cayrol vous qui avez raconté votre
voyage au coeur de la Cinquième
République comment vous vous voyez la
suite qu'est-ce qui va se passer comment
on redonne de l'énergie à ce quinquennat
j'étais de ceux qui étaient contents qui
est une majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale précisément pour créer de la
culture du compromis précisément pour
donner de la souplesse à nos
institutions et bien je vais vous dire
que je dois être un dernier optimiste
mais je conserve un peu cette option je
crois que c'est dur c'est plus dur pour
les pour les majoritaires relatifs parce
que c'est à elle de s'adapter d'abord
c'est à elle de s'habituer au fait
qu'elles ont plus le pouvoir sur le
Parlement ça suppose des pratiques mais
les autres aussi et moi je crois que il
reste quand même près de quatre ans et
je ne peux pas imaginer que les
institutions soient bloquées on est
capable de compromis dans nos vies
familiales social professionnel pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas merci beaucoup on
s'arrête là merci infiniment d'être venu
débattre une heure en direct de cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
merci aux équipes de la Chaîne
Parlementaire Marco pommier avec
Charlotte cebir Stéphanie Despierre avec
Marion Duvauchelle merci à vous très
belle soirée sur la chaîne parlementaire
et à très bientôt merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]